this sequence of lovers once I put a
third number in here in the middle okay
I will be able to know because I will
set up the pattern we establish the you
only need three numbers to know what a
sequence actually is what kind of
signals is okay now we know about
different kinds of sequences are two
particular families of sequences that
we're really interested in and they are
of course progressions right there and
GPS geometry providers now do you
remember um what's it last lesson it
might have been lost missing on
Wednesday I can make any sequence I like
if there's like unknowns in there right
I can make this sequence in AP or if I
want I could make it a GP depending on
what number I put in there right because
since I don't know yet it's still you
know a chance okay now I've chosen a
really small numbers what number should
make this an AP oh sure okay good I
think I think I followed that somehow
fourth term snuck in let me see if I
understand we have a look at this gap
this gap here and the gap is six plus
six if there is one number intervening
between those that means that plus six
really represents two steps of plus
three plus three that makes sense
doesn't it okay so fostering plus 3
okayed that that's fine all right
let's think about it another way okay
this is not mark five it has a important
relationship with the numbers two and
eight right it's not just a random
number the number five
like I couldn't have just on this
instead of taking the difference I could
have added these two two plus eight and
to get to five I would divide by two
why was
work why does that give me the number
that I want it's the average isn't it
right it's like I want the another word
for average in our context is midpoint
right and we know exactly what the
midpoint formula looks like it's yeah x1
plus x2 on two and the wise as well okay
so if you want to get somewhere right
bang in the middle and you're going
bye-bye pluses you'll take the average
okay that's fine okay well by the way we
have another word for average a more
technical once after than m-mean right
okay now let's label this five is the
mean of two and eight it's the mean of
two and eight
but it's the particular mean that makes
it an arithmetic progression so I'm
going to be a little more fun I call
this the arithmetic mean okay now you've
never had to qualify the word mean
before with an adjective because you
haven't known about any other man that's
the only client that there is in fact
there are many many different kinds of
means I'll tell you about at least two
more today but one more is important to
us let me write these are sequence of
numbers again and then eight now I want
to think geometric okay what number
could I pop in the middle there
in order to make this a GP I could put
okay so how did how did someone brain
contort to get that and it's fine okay
let's try and make a comparison to what
we did up here you see what we did here
so instead of thinking about what would
I and I'm in GP mode right so I'm gonna
need to think about what I would
multiply by because that's what makes it
a GP right so I went from here to here
that's two steps and I'm multiplying by
four right to get from two days that was
the next thing I was going to say okay
so I should write my time so it's really
so now I just need to think about just
like if I do plus three plus three I'll
have plus six
what multiplication can I do twice in
order to get four and of course if
you're if you're Brendan you say well
sorry
that'll get me there and sure enough it
will okay because if you say I've got a
number if I swear I'll get four there
are two solutions so let's be let's be a
little more accurate now and say this is
really plus or minus okay I could put
either of those numbers in and sure
enough I would get a GP okay now this
this is a number that in a real sense is
still in middle middle invite economies
of these two numbers it's just in the
middle in a different way okay
it still mean and because it's a mean
that we think of in terms of a GP in
terms of a geometric context we call
that those surprises the geometric mean
now I'll let you I'll leave it for your
thought as to why on earth you would
want like in what context wouldn't that
make me or a geometric mean make more
sense
there are lots more I would just please
for you one of the most interesting
means that I think I know that is called
the harmonic mean I'm just thinking I
turned on this here the harmonic mean is
if you have two numbers you're two
divided by the reciprocals of the two
numbers right and together that looks
really weird what on earth could that be
useful for I'll let you have another
okay oh don't you do a bit more of a
clue at the end but not going to come
out and tell you because it's more
interesting if you try to find out
yourself okay so these two numbers here
right the arithmetic mean also known is
that everything gets abbreviated in this
topic the a.m. and the geometric mean
the GM okay it's not hard to find when
you've just got actual numbers right now
let's think
abstract okay let's think
oh by the way that was kind of your own
problem woods now I want to think
algebraically because I'm not always
gonna get to and am i I'm gonna get all
kinds of different things right so if I
have two numbers and I'm gonna call them
a and B okay I've got a comma something
and then B I literally have on the board
what am I gonna do to this two numbers
and what way can I combine them in order
to get this number in the middle for an
AP can you see it's a little bit
actually right there about all I want to
take the arithmetic mean the average
right that's the average we're familiar
with okay so that's just you add those
numbers together and divide okay / - are
you happy with that this will always be
an AP you can put any numbers you like
in there very positive negative anything
is going to work in our two five eight
example cruiser dot dot this is our
formula for the a.m. okay that's our
formula just like we had a formula for
the nth term and we had a formula for
we're going to get quite a few formulas
in here that's one for the a.m. okay now
I think this one's a little more tricky
right if I still have a and B but I want
the GM now think about the process we
went through to get this but how it
compares to this hmm how did we end up
with four or more specifically plus or
minus four
it's actually clear by the way yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're on our track just
pause for a second before you go on and
finish your thought all the views should
be thinking you should be suspicious and
think of square roots gonna do that
somehow because where where else do we
get plus or minuses coming up right so
when you take the square root of both
sides or something and you need to have
both
okay you want try to finish your thought
okay here we got the numbers right is
that right so you have a look here right
I combined the first and third terms by
addition here because it's in AP but I
want to combine the first in 30 by
multiplication because it's a GP are you
getting this right so in the middle key
what I start off doing is I take the
product right now you can see where
there are two by eight you're getting 16
so to come back to the middle instead of
dividing by two you're gonna take that
on whatever enters your mind you're
gonna take the square root okay now as
we have noticed that you rendon okay
this is not the only option for the GM
you can get the plus or minus we saw in
our first lesson on GPS you can get that
alternating thing remember that black
green black green black green so I can
do plus or minus in here and they're
both fine okay this is our formula or
the gia okay